uh but who who else has been like the
most random person that's like just
tapped in like whether it's a someone
who just reposted you or dm'd you or
that Mike Tyson tight yesterday Mike
Tyson and Styles P oh I saw that yeah
with the Angie Martinez yeah yeah that
was dope and I recently ran into a con
in Atlanta great hair oh man he's going
crazy yeah I love that he's going crazy
I'm interviewing him tomorrow tell him I
said what's up I will but I ran into a
Con in Atlanta and he was like yeah man
you know I've been seeing your
freestyles I'm gonna check out your
project so literally about four hours
goes by and my phone's ringing it's Akon
wow I was just about to get on stage in
Atlanta I had like 20 minutes before I
got on stage and he was like yo
he's like man this [ __ ] album's
incredible he was like I ain't heard
nothing like this in five years which I
don't understand why Kev got me at five
um he said I haven't heard nothing like
this in five years this is some real
[ __ ] rap records like you talking
some real [ __ ] some relatable [ __ ] right
which I don't understand why Kev asked
me at five but he was like this [ __ ]
isn't [ __ ] incredible I'm like damn
con I really appreciate that because I
grew up like literally watching you like
learning how to write hooks listening to
Akon and T-Pain so the fact that he
rocked with it and bullet Kev did it I
do what do you mean I love the album you
said it was number five that's great you
like it you don't love it if I bro I
love every other album I in my top 10 I
have so after that I have like Joey okay
uh what other album I love I love I love
the Kodak Black Album so that's cool I
got a great uh kodak's album was hard
kodak's a generational Talent I think he
doesn't get enough credit I'm really
looking forward to hearing what this
little baby album sounds like too
because yeah my turn was like a classic
so you think it was a classic I think my
turn is yeah I think we're gonna look
back and it's gonna be uh regarded as a
classic for sure I can't argue that yeah
I think I don't think it's a classic now
but I think like over time over time
we're gonna be like damn my time you
know what I'm saying yeah that's true
yeah I just think like you know yeah
shout out to baby